[Musique]
ancien coureur cycliste Steven leyaric
s'est trouvé une âme
d'aventurier à 33 ans il accomplit à
vélo la traversée de l'imalaya palais
sur une des traces les plus difficiles
au monde le Great himalay
tril 2000 km à parcourir en moins de 60
jours et 20 cols à franchir à plus de
5000 m d'altitude c'est le défi que
s'est lancé cet amoureux des
montagnes rouler sur l'impossible au
plus près des étoiles avec comme seul
objectif la réalisation de son rêve
[Musique]
d'Himalaya
j'ai eu peur j'ai eu peur 1000 fois mais
là ouais là c'est parti je réalise pas
vraiment encore et tant que je serais
pas arrivé à C mondo j'aurais pas
réalisé mais ou ouais je suis encore
sous tension et bord des
larmes c'est beaucoup de travail pour un
gros rêve mais bon c'est comme ça c'est
[Musique]
l'aventure je navigue encore entre le
stress et l'excitation j'ai tout laissé
derrière moi il y aura un avant et un
après l'Himalaya le Népal c'est le toit
du monde une fine bande de terre coincée
entre deux géants asiatiques l'Inde et
la Chine
[Musique]
l'arrivée je retrouve un je ch F de vélo
de te
rencontrer il sera mon guide pour les
deux prochain
[Musique]
mois
Himal est la trace la plus longue au
mondeoupem sont des sentiers
locauxile avec la montagne avec la
route aussi parce que c'est
sontit le
cor sera également le chef mécanicien
beaucoup de choses reposent sur
lui première des choses à faire tester
nos vélos car dans les montagnes nous
pourrons difficilement
réparer notre vol pour l'Est du pays et
dans 3 jours seulement en attendant j'en
profite pour déambuler dans la ville qui
a chamboulé ma vie car ce n'est pas la
première fois que je viens à catmandou
il y a 2 ans j'ai passé 4 mois ici c'est
ici que mes n idée de cette aventure
allier mes deux passions la montagne et
le
[Musique]
vélo la vallée de catemandou c'est le
cœur du
Népal les plateaux autour de la ville
bénéficie de sol remarquablement
fertile sur les champs en terrasse le
blé s'épanoué en hiver juste avant la
plantation du riz le climat permet trois
récoltes par
an dans la région le VTT a fait son
apparition dans les années 80 avec les
expatriés voulant découvrir les collines
alentour il n'est pas rare de croiser
des cyclistes mais aujourd'hui c'est mon
vélo qui intrigue les
[Musique]
habitants j'ai toujours fait du vélo je
suis fait pour ça
j'ai longtemps fait de la compétition en
tant que courur élite dans l'épreuve
j'avais assez de mental pour sortir le
meilleur de moi-même mais au fond de moi
je n'étais pas heureux ma vie n'avait
aucun
sens alors j'ai tout arrêté pour
découvrir qui j'étais vraiment j'ai pris
un allé simple pour quat mandou là en
quête de spiritualité j'ai commencé à
ranger le désordre dans mon esprit j'ai
même pensé devenir moine pour me rendre
utile je suis devenu prof d'anglais dans
plusieurs écoles de la ville tu te
rappelles tu te souviens de
moi je suis heureux de vous
revoir vous allez
bien au Népal l'école est gratuite et
obligatoire de la 6e à la 11e année mais
beaucoup d'enfants arrêtent bien avant
seul 84 % des Népalais sont
scolarisés le système éducatif est dans
un sale état il manque du personnel
qualifié et des locaux toi tu
[Musique]
veux cette école malheureusement va
disparaître on est à l'école où j'étais
prof l'an passé et ça a pas changé on
m'avait dit que le gouvernement
changerait construirait soit une autre
école soit au moins un toit c'est un des
problèmes politiques en fait c'est cette
rivière ils veulent faire une route ici
donc ils ont détruit des habitations sur
cette route là et ils vont en faire un
lieu de passage du coup ils veulent
détruire cette école et et ses étudiants
n'auront pas de d'école où aller là il
m'a demandé le le prof de les aider
encore d'essayer de faire le maximum
pour essayer de les aider financièrement
à reconstruire au moins un toit et et
pourquoi pas une école et
[Musique]
voilà
à très
[Musique]
vite l'école est en plein bidonville
c'est une décharge à ciel
ouvert
on les jette dans la rivière un geste
qui me révulse totalement mais qui n'a
rien d'anormal ici malheureusement c'est
ainsi dans de nombreuses villes
[Musique]
asiatiques le Népal est un pays aux
coutumes très ancienne et assz
déroutante pour un européen comme moi
elles exercent pourtant un pouvoir de
fascination
véritable l'hindouisme et le bouddhisme
dominent le pays mais 80 % de la
population se dit hindou
apachou patinate les défunts sont
transportés jusqu'au gâes de crémation
au bord de la rivière les bûchiers sont
continuellement enfumés les morts se
consument lentement à la vue de
tous les cendres rejoignant ensuite le
Gange MRE de tous les
fleuves au Népal la perception de la vie
change étrangement les esprits sont
fortement
sollicités c'est ce qui m'attire dans ce
pays unequiétude
[Musique]
permanente
en lisière de la ville sur une bute
verdoyante se dresse le majestueux
stoupa de soyan bodenat il y a plus de
2500 ans le légendaire patriage manjouri
aurait découvert à cet endroit l'ancien
lac de la vallée et son Lotus
emblématique c'est le plus saint des
sites bouddhistes de Katmandou et l'un
des plus anciens sites religieux du
Népal
[Musique]
le calme m'envahit
subitement chaque matin avant l'aube les
pèlerins montent les 365 marches qui
mènent en haut de la colline avant de
pratiquer la Cora une révolution autour
du stoupa dans le sens des aiguilles
d'une montre en signe de respect et de
soumission à la base le dô blanc
signifie la création il représente le
monde
au-dessus du dô est posée une structure
cubique avec les yeux de Bouddha qui
regardent vers les quatre points
cardinaux enfin 13 anneau d'or viennent
chapoter le tout il représente les 13
degrés de connaissance qu'il faut avoir
pour gravir le chemin de l'éveil et
atteindre le nirvana on est au Sambu
temple qui appelé le Monke temple par
les Occidentaux qui est mon temple
préféré à Cat mandou pour pour des
dizaines de raisons mais la principale
c'est que il est en hauteur j'ai
toujours été bien ici ça a été le
premier temple que j'ai visité lors de
mon dernier voyage ici et ça m'a
toujours àaiser c'est toujours le
premier endroit où je viens quand je
viens à catmandou donc voilà j'y venais
tous les jours j'adore être là j'adore
j'adore voir ces petits singes qui
courent partout j'adore ouais cet
apaisement qui arrive lorsqu'on fait
tout le tour on fait tourner ses moulin
à prière et cetera je j'adore être
ici
accroché au stoupa des bannières de
tissu coloré présentent les textes
sacrés le bleu pour l'espace le blanc
pour l'air le rouge pour le feu le vert
pour l'eau et le jaune pour la terre
tout ici a un sens et chaque
frémissement du tissu dans le vent
libère les prières vers le
ciel je suis chargé d'ondes positive un
an que j'attends ça traverser l'Himalaya
sur mon vélo dans des paysages
grandioses à la rencontre des
Népalais mais il me fallait un défi
également plus physique j'ai donc choisi
la trace la plus haute et la plus
difficile le greet Himalaya
trail dernier échauffement sur les
collines de catmandou histoire de se
mettre en
jambe au sud du pays les terres sont à
peine au niveau de la mer mais au nord
là où nous allons se dressent les plus
hautes montagnes de la planète et les
plus dangereuses avec mon guide nous
allons les traverser d'est en ouest sur
km je sens queaang a une aime de
compétiteur j'étais comme lui à 20 ans
mais pour moi la vitesse s
terminée espérons que ce jeu entre nous
ne prenne pas le
dessus au-delà de l'effort physique
c'est surtout l'aventure humaine que je
recherche et les
rencontres
ça descend vite et nous n'aurons que
rarement ce genre de
[Musique]
piste làhaut les chemins sont bien plus
étroits et plus
[Musique]
escarpés nous préparons nos sac et celui
du porteur
également à pied il faut 5 mois vir bout
dual moi je me suis donné 60 jours pas
plus mon sac pèse 14 kg sans compter le
vélo qu'il faudra porter sur une bonne
partie du
parcours enfin nous faisons un point sur
la carte avant de nous coucher une
dernière fois dans la nuit de
C tu sais cette partie est vraiment
difficile c'est peut-être 4 ou 6
jours quelle partie est difficile
celle-là oui celle-ci est vraiment
compliquée et celle-là
aussi je me rends compte que nous
partons à l'aveuglette mais c'est ça
l'aventure au fond de moi j'espère que
haong se trompe et que nous pourront
faire plus de vélos que
prévus direction badrapour un petit
aéroport de campagne à la frontière avec
l'Inde tout à l'est du pays puis 10
longues heures de route en 44 jusqu'à
tale J où nous commencerons vraiment à
[Musique]
pédaler j'ai toujours été malade en
voiture et le Népal c'est le cauchemar
de tous les estomacs
fragiles avec les virages qui se succède
mon corps décroche petit à
[Musique]
petit
au bout de 8h de route c'est encore pire
je tétanise dans la
voiture mes camarades commencent
sérieusement à douter du sportif que je
suis moi aussi et si ce projet était
trop dur pour
moi tiens de l'eau c'est de la
Bonneau
B
bike
ready ready
for
yes
[Applaudissements]
cette fois c'est parti et le temps nous
est
compté nous prenons la direction du camp
de base de kjunga à 5160 m d'altitude
c'est le vrai point de départ du Gret
Himalaya TR mais il faudra une semaine
pour l'atteindre si tout va
[Musique]
bien
nous traversons nos premiers villages
les enfants cassent les pierres les
femmes sont paré de leurs plus beaux
atour r
massif les regards sont
intenses ça fait du bien de faire
vraiment du vélo et vraiment parce que
làang est parti est parti très vite j'
tis pas du tout réveillé puis j'étais
encore un peu patraque d'hier et là au
pied de la montée il m'a attaqué une
fois deux fois trois fois j'ai rien dit
et puis à la 4rième fois je lu dit ciao
il dit ciao et puis je suis
parti je veux simplement rouler très
proche de
lui quand il s'agit de grimper
il est beaucoup plus rapide que
moi je rou PRS lui parce que je
veux les des suiv mais dans les monté
c'est
impossible
prèreaison
nous sommes mi-mars il fait 25 degr la
piste est dans un sale état mais encore
praticable à vélo ça monte et ça descend
très
fort connait bien mon parcours de
sportif il n'hésite pas pourtant à
prodiguer ses conseils même pour poser
mon
vélo ça fait 25 ans que je fais du tu
sais
comm ça il est
bien les jeunes sont tous regroupés
autour du car une sorte de bière
indien le but placer des pions de
couleur dans les trous situ au CO de la
table tout le monde joue dans
P
mais pas le temps de s'attarder nous
avons de la route à faire 2000
km la vie au nord du pays est rude
soumise à l'altitude et au manque de
précipitation les habitants se sont
traditionnellement tournés vers le
commerce traversant à pied les géantes
montagnes sionnant de minuscules
sentiers de village en village avec le
caravane De Mul ou de
yak allez les
[Musique]
gars ong est lui aussi un aventurier
c'est un jeune charpa mais un bon
cycliste et il a de
l'ambition c'est comme un
rve pouvoir explorer mon pays à travers
le
Himal ce que j'aimerais c'est devenir le
meilleur cycliste du Népal un
jour mais c'est pas facile d'y arriver
il faut que je
m'accroche en 2 3 ans je peux atteindre
le deè niveau et
après je veux passer au premier niveau
être le
meilleur au 3è jour c'est le début des
hostilités je m'y étais
préparé les chemins ne permettent plus
de rouler il faut porter le vélo en plus
de mon sac à
doster
leélo en tout une trentaine de kilos un
peu moins que le sac de notre porteur
qui nous rejoint en fin de
journée j'ai une affection vraiment
particulière pour pour les porteurs pour
moi c'est c'est la quintessence de de
l'effort quoi être porteur c'est porter
les habits matériel de d'expédition de
longues expéditions mais aussi mais
aussi pour travailler il porte il porte
du lait il porte des casseroles des fois
des armoires des fois des des tlons du
lait et ils portent leur vie avec eux
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai décidé de de
garder un sac lourd et de de monter ce
projet aussi en en portant notre
matériel portant nos vélos mais j'ai
tellement de respect pour ces gens-là et
je vois tellement d'apaisement dans leur
dans leurs yeux dans leur vie j'ai
l'impression que c'est tous les jours
une longue
méditationwang il faisait ça quand il
avait 8 9 ans il a commencé il portait
déjà entre 25 et 45 kg je suis vraiment
touché par par ces ces hommes ces femmes
qui qui pent tous les jours ouais un peu
un peu de nous quoi un peu de nous sur
leur dos et et qui se plaignent
[Musique]
jamais dans les hautes montagnes du
Népal les porteurs sont indispensables
aux expéditions et à la survie des
villages il n'y a aucun autre moyen
d'acheminer les
[Musique]
marchandises
n progressons lentement le long de la
rivière à son arrivée notre porteur
décide d'abandonner l'aventure le sac
est trop lourd pour
lui ils vont s'engueuler pendant un
moment je pense et là le porteur veut
partir donc ils ont appelé son frère
tous les deux parce que G s engage avec
son frère et cetera beaucoup de drôle
d'histoire heureusement on a des chèvres
avec nous parce que pour l'instant je
m'enmèle pas je le laisse gérer sais que
c'est dur pourang parce que il a déjà
craqué hier ou avantier aussi c'est pas
facile l'aventure c'est un choix c'est
un choix de partir 60 jours comme ça et
de laisser sa vie derrière soi et et d'
commencer une autre dans la difficulté
mais c'est ça end beaucoup quoi le
problème c'est que sans porteur la suite
de l'aventure va être
[Musique]
compliquée finalement c'est à noir un
villageois un peu fou qui le
[Rires]
remplacera
la nuit sera parfaite entre le bruit de
la rivière et le ciel
[Musique]
étoilé aujourd'hui il faut aller le plus
haut possible grosse journée de portage
en
perspective il faut que je commence à me
caler
[Musique]
avec le vélo portage tout ça et ça va
aller
mais bout de journée c'est toujours dur
pour
[Musique]
moi des plateaux désertiques au Vallé
luxuriante les paysages changent vite
sur de courtes distances la végétation
se transforme
radicalement de 2000 à 3000 m d'altitude
c'est une zone tempérée chaud chaude
elle précède une zone tempérée froide de
4000 à 5000 m d'altitude on trouve les
dernières traces de végétation plus haut
ce sont les neiges éternelles les glaces
et les vents qui
dominent le chemin a été tracé par des
locaux qui le travaillent chaque année
un peu plus face à des vaches ou des
porteurs chargés à bloc il est difficile
de se croiser sur un sentier d'un m
seulement avec sur le côté souvent de
sacré Pr
pendant la saison des pluies les ponts
de fortune sont emportés par les
rivières en cru isolant un peu plus les
villages en
hauteur à l'automne les villageois
reconstruisent les PS en bois
rétablissant le lien avec les
vallées dès que c'est possible enforche
son vélo même pour quelques
mètres
après les 20 km de montée nous arrivons
au lodge
épuiséuras jamais fini comme
ça est un fan de je vidéo et tous les
soirs s'amuser un peu
ensuite comme si les efforts de la
journée n'av pas suffis nous nous
mettons au travailang a coupé du bois
toute sa jeunesse il ne s'arrête plus
[Musique]
les bûches rangées empilé nous pouvons
enfin nous
[Musique]
reposer le temps s'écoule différemment
au Népal les nuits sont longues et
réparatrices pour le petit-déjeuner
c'est chapati ce sont de petites
galettes de blé souvent accompagné de
pommes de terre au
[Musique]
curé tous les jours le sac est de plus
en plus
gros
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bu
ça veut dire que je suis passé ici
plusieurs
fois c'est comme comme une prière pour
Dieu tissu des fleurs ou de
l'argent vers la fin de la journée la
trace est un peu plus praticable haang
est euphorique j'accélère mais il ne
baisse pas les bras au contraire c'est
très excitant mais à 3500 m d'altitude
c'est dur pour moi de rester dans sa
roue à l'entrée du village malgré la
fatigue et le manque d'oxygène je suis
heureux d'entendre les rires des enfants
étonné voir arver là des
[Musique]
Vél je suis arrivé trop
tard je tuiss 18h30
ça je sais bien que c'est difficile à
porter oui c'est vra j'avou c'est peu
dur dans les
monter
nous sommes une dizaine autour du poil
un homme m'explique que j'intimide les
femmes avec ma barbe et ma
stature le jour se lève les fumées
envahissent l'air alors que le soleil
allume les
sommets 'est tu fais
toi nous prenons la direction de CEN le
camp de bas d'approche de toutes les
expéditions vers le le trè plus ha
sommet du
monde les effets de l'altitude se font
sentir dè 200 m plus haut on risque le
mal des montagnesz
l'incacité just à une ascension trop
rapide ce sont des céphalés des nausées
et une grande fatigue dans le pire des
cas il peut se transformer en odème
cérébrale ou
pulmonaire mes jambes sont fatiguées
mais j'ai hâte d'y arriver si tout se
passe bien nous y serons dans 48
he
je pensais que c'était trop
là là je suis plus trop dans mon univers
ouis j'ai j'ai passé des moment pas
facile et on a passé 7h à porter le vélo
sur des pentes très très compliquées
même avec pas mal de cailloux avec avec
200 m de vide en dessous commence à être
attentif
là je commence à avoir un tout petit peu
mal à la tête un peu voir flou et tout
donc on va s'arrêter boire manger puis
voilà c'est ça l'altitude faut gérer
tout le temps son effort j'ai hâte
d'être d'être à 4007 d'êre la hauteur du
Montblanc donc rendez-vous à Keng junga
maintenant on va essayer d'aller
[Musique]
d'ici jusqu'à
lonac mais lonac est fermé tous les
lodges sont verrouillés alors on ira
demain
si on y va
aujourd'hui faudra dormir
dehors tu vois c'est un gros
problème c'est
la c'est le repas le plus efficace et le
plus
diététique pour
les les alpinistes ici y en a qui
mangent que
ça
et tu prends des calories un indice
glycémi hyper B hyper
efficace ça va nousett sur pied on
pouter
he après la sol tibée à d'or nous av
traditionnelal
lentill bat le
riz le dalbat les népalis en mange deux
fois par jour c'est de l'énergie pour 24
heur là ce sont des
pâteses sont salé très salé des pâtes
avec des
légumes il est pire que les enfants ce
mec ça c'est la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui
avec de la belle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
musique les paysages du Népal sont issu
d'un violent télescopage géologique
encore actif aujourd'hui il y a 50
millions d'années le sous-continent
indien est venu se frotter à la plaque
curasienne déclenchant des tremblements
de terre et faisant ainsi naître
l'Himalaya centimètres par
[Musique]
centimètre l'Himalaya c'est la demeure
des neiges en tibétain une chaîne de
montagne qui s'étire sur plus de 2800 km
du nord du Pakistan au sud-est de la
Chine température
extérieure je sais qu 0
de les été ils sont courts et les hivers
rigoureux accompagné d'impressionnantes
chutes de neige et de vent
violents un trè au Népal est une
fascination particulière difficilement
explicable l'imaginaire joue ici un rôle
important imprégné de la quête du
changrila décrit par Jam silton dans les
horizons
perdus il s'agit d'un lieu dans lequel
on voit de splendides paysages et où le
temps est suspendu dans une atmosphère
de paix et de
tranquillité le paradis des ciments
[Musique]
sorte nous sommes partis trop tard ce
matin il faut avancer vite car nous
devons absolument revenir au camp de
basse pour dormir là-haut en cette
saison tous les refuges sont
[Applaudissements]
fermés mais soudain la neige se met à
tomber des petits flocons d'abord puis
des plus gros bien plus
collants nous sommes à 4 km du but mais
la neige recouvre la piste nous n'avons
pas le choix que de rebrousser
chemins
on doit s'arrêter quoi là on peut plus
continuer on peut plus faire de vélo on
a tout
tenté et du coup là il fait une
cérémonie peut-être en pensant que c'est
le vrai départ de notre expédition et et
ça ne l'est pas parce que on n pas
atteint le camp de base et pour moi pour
moi ça a pas vraiment
commencé
donc là il fait une
[Musique]
cérémonie avec des flagues pour nous
protéger il y a toujours un moment dans
les expéditions où on comprend pourquoi
pourquoi on est on a fait le choix de
venir là c'est ça que je viens chercher
c'est c'est la réalité quoi c'est la
nature c'est les éléments c'est la
difficulté c'est la neige le froid c'est
le mal des montagnes qui me guettete
voilà et puis et puis euh ouais elle a
aller chercher quelque chose quoi donc
là même en en revenant là où on était on
va aller chercher quelque chose en nous
chacun et et demain on en sortira
différent grandi je pense mais en tous
les cas différents et et voilà c'est ça
l'aventure telle que telle que je la
conçois c'est-à-dire vivre quelque chose
et et le partager et le montrer aussi
parce que parce que là c'est un petit
échec on est là pour jouer avec la
nature mais la nature elle joue
pas nous avons pu rejoindre le campement
et dormir trois petites
heures l'énergie et l'envie sont là rien
ne pourra
[Musique]
m'arrêter
la neige est tombée en masse cette
nuit autour de nous des sommets à plus
de 7000 m d'altitude des cérac et des
corniches
[Musique]
glacées
la neige glisse sous mes pieds le
souffle court et le froid sec me frappe
le
[Musique]
visage je commence doucement à me mettre
dans ma bulle il faut être concentré
pour affronter les
éléments j'ai appris cela en faisant du
vélo devenir en quelques minutes un
animal de courage et de
volonté ce projet en plus d'être ancré
dans une certaine spiritualité est aussi
un défi physique et
[Musique]
psychologique finalement nous arrivons
face au k chengjunga le troisè plus haut
sommet de de la planète
8586 m d'altitude c'est l'une des parois
les plus impressionnantes de la terre
redouté par les plus grands
[Musique]
alpinistes cette fois-ci on y est ça
c'est kcheng jonga plus de 8500 m c'est
le 3è sommet du monde ça ponctue une
première une première semaine très très
difficile ici euh surtout surtout sur la
climatation en altitude au-dessus de
4000 ça ça commence à être dur pour nous
là on est à on est à plus de 5000 m 5140
c'est aussi le début du Gret himalay
tril et voilà c'est un retour aux
sources parce que là on est à la
montagne la vraie montagne avec des
vélos et c'est c'est ça aussi le
mountain bike en tout cas au Népal c'est
ça ça fait plaisir d'être ici et ouais
c'est cool parce que par qu'on a eu des
conditions incroyables du coup on a eu
que du
blanc c'est très difficile d'arriver
jusque là
avec des chemins
compliqués tu es dans ton
jardin finalement on est arrivé au camp
de base et on est heureux je suis hyper
content on a été au bout du truc
maintenant c'est le vrai départ on va
pouvoir on va pouvoir savourer il reste
plus que 40 jours 45
jours la véritable aventure commence ici
c'est le point de départ de mon rêve
d'Himalaya
nous redescendons jusqu'à gunsa et
bifuron vers l'ouest direction
hongchongola un ancien village de
réfugiés
tibétain on arrive àou et
vraisemblablement c'est c'est un
événement qu'on arrive parce que fait
ils ont jamais vu de
[Musique]
vélo ici les siècles sont passés sans
laisser de trace
avec e c'est
[Musique]
toi pr du vélo à
plus de 4000 m c'est quand même pas
mal pas si beaucoup de gens roulé ici en
tout cas moi je suis content je suis
content d'être
là on s'est levé à 2h30 ce matin on est
parti à 3h et
là là c'est notre premier vrai stop quoi
ça c'est ma main après non après 10
jours de gratral de portage non et ça
c'est mon
pied très
[Musique]
sympa c'est
bon
engaang part comme une flèche lui aussi
a besoin de se prouver quelque chose
mais nous allons trop vite et je n'ose
pas lui dire dans ce genre d'aventure il
faut savoir aller loin sans s'abîmer en
somme il faut accepter ses limites c'est
parti pour lumbaumba pass
naang dans ses
uvres pour 3
He pas passer trop de neige il ESS de
trouver une solution mais j'ai
l'impression qu'il est
[Musique]
perdu on va monter
ça le Gret Himalaya tril est une trace
qui change tous les jours en fonction de
la météo aujourd'hui avec la neige elle
est carrément
invisible nous nous arrachons tous les
deux le souffle
court me demande
d'accélérer je suis mort il me demande
d'accélérer est plus de
5000 il fou ce
type nous enchaînons l'école le nangol
la passe à
4766 m puis le Lumba Sumba passe à 5520
m
d'altitude ça y est je le tienspire M de
de
séjour on VI s'engueuler avec sa rangue
c'est
fort il va trop vite comprends pas que
il doit m'attendre il a peur qu'on
[Musique]
bloqu rapidement la neige disparaît pour
faire place à la végétation nous
trouvons refuge dans une ferme un peu
plus
bas comment tu
vas bien
sur le toit
deak les peuples ici partagent un
héritage tibétain dominé par le
boudhisme dans les hautes montagnes
certaines communautés ont gardé leur
tradition
chamanique au coin du feu je participe
au rituel censé nous
protéger
à l'or du jour les femmes sont les
premières debout pour River les
braises un rapide petit déjeuner et nous
devons
partir
B je fais comment là je fais pupis sur
moi
ou je connais pas beaucoup de pays il
peut faire moins 5 un
jour le lendemain 25 30° à 20 km
d'écart avant la première difficulté du
jour c'est les
M manif on veut des Vélos Vélo non pas
de vélo c'est sans doute la première
fois qu'il VO un
vélo je trouve ça
cool j'espère qu'un jour ils en auront
que c'est cool de faire du
vélo les jours se suivent mais ne se
ressembl
pas a cassé sa roue arrière
depuis le début de l'expédition il
enchaîne les
problèmes dans le village de Bong il
tente en vin de réparer son vélo mais il
doit finalement se résigner et repart
sur qu mandou pour changer sa
[Musique]
roue
en attendant le retour de hawang je
poursuis seul mon aventure et ça me
plaît fini la course je prends mon temps
[Musique]
tranquillement
dans ce pays nous sommes loin de la
propriété privée occidentale typique de
la petite
bourgeoisie la porte ici n'est jamais
close pas besoin d'autorisation pour
rentrer devant la maison s'étend la cour
souvent de TER BTU c'est un lieu
important on y réceptionne les récoltes
on y étend le linge on y accueille les
vaches on y passe une longue partie de
la
vieit est très simple au Népal les
maisons sont faites de briques de Bou de
bambou ou de roseau avec un toit de
chaôume et parfois de
[Musique]
tôle c'est ma
mère j'étais un peu malade en fait ça
fait de 3 jours que je suis malade je
pense j'ai un contrecoup des 15 jours
qu'on a passé ensemble avec naang où
c'était cétait un peu la course de se
lever parfois 2h du matin partir à 2h30
et d'être d'être tout le temps épuisé et
d'être tout le temps dans dans une
course une course que je suis depuis
depuis longtemps quoi c'est pas le sens
du projet donc là j'essaie de j'essaie
de revenir à moi-même j'essaie de de
revenir au fondamentaux de ce projet
c'està-dire à la rencontre des gens
rencontre des populations bien sûr que
il y a il y a un fond d'esprit
d'aventure il y a un fond de challenge
il un fond de de record de quelqu chose
de de nouveau
mais on n pas là pour faire la course
[Musique]
quoi j'enchaîne les montées les
descentes mais ici impossible de les
faire en vélo les pentes sont bien trop
raides je dois me battre pour rester sur
mes
jambes
[Musique]
son je n'ai fait que 500 km depuis le
départ une trentaine par jour
seulement mon vélo ne m'est pas d'un
grand secours pour l'instant c'est même
plutôt un poids donc je me passerai
bien alors j'avance et je souffre en
silence il me reste encore plus de 1500
km à parcourir et de nombreux cols à
passer ce ne sera pas facile mais je
suis venu pour me surpasser et réaliser
mon rêve
[Musique]
je suis entre deux eau je suis mis bien
mis
[Musique]
maloi
faire c'est le défi que s'est lancé cet
amoureux des
montagnes rouler sur l'impossible au
plus près des étoiles avec comme se
objectif la réalisation de son rêve
[Musique]
d'Himalaya depuis Apple Jung avec le
charpaaong monid nous avons mis une
semaine pour atteindre le camp de base
du kengunga trè plus haut sommet du
monde c'est aussi le point de départ du
Gret himalay
TR là on est à la montagne la vraie
montagne depuis nous nous arrachons vélo
sur le dos dans des descentes
vertigineuses et des montées
[Musique]
diaboliques 3 semaines déjà que nous
roulons sur le ciel dans la neige ou
dans la moiteur de la
jungleong a cassé sa rou arrière il
partir sur catmandou pour la faire
réparer je poursuis donc seul mon
aventure jusqu'à son retour il me reste
1500 km à parcourir dans les villages on
m'accueille les bras ouverts avec des
sourires qui me réchauffent le cœur mais
qu'est-ce que tu fais
[Musique]
toi
je suis à présent sur la trace basse du
Gret Himalaya trille c'est la
jungle dans cette partie du Népal
l'élevage et l'agriculture sont très
présents les forêts ont disparu et les
terrasses occupent les pentes
inhospitalières les générations antièr
ont consacré une énergie considérable
pour défricher les versants abruptes et
créer des terrasses cultivables
[Musique]
de nos jours les efforts continuent
encore pour les entretenir car l'érosion
ici- bas les menass
[Musique]
continuellement tout le monde on Népal
est agriculteur le moindre lopin de
terre est
cultivé les récoltes sont toutes
destinées à la consommation rares sont
les paysans qui les
[Musique]
vendent poème n'est pasit assez beau sur
l'agriculture l'heure du repiquage
l'éclair a zébré le tonner a chanté le
ruisseau bondit sous les nuées et fait
danser mon cœur les taches de Bou mûis
sur ta blouse jolis ornements qui se
soucie que demain la mort nous
cuueille au-dessus des cultures des
forêts dansses peuple les
sommets
quand les enfants ne sont pas à l'école
ils conduisent les bêtes au champ ramè
le bois de chauffe c'est rare de les
voir
[Musique]
s'amuser les parties à vélo sont limité
pour l'instant je le porte sur le dos
comme un lourd fardeau 60% du temps
musculairement parlant les cuisses
travaillent très fort et mes quadriceps
sont déjà dans un sale
état heureusement rencontre for soulage
ma solitude mon vélo
intrigue de me faire piquer mon
vélo sur la route
deerie je leurais dit siil voulait me
tenir le vélo et en fait ils comprennent
pas bien l'anglais comme beaucoup
ici du coup ils sont en train de le
pousser c'est plutôt drôle ça tombe bien
aujourd'hui
c'est c'est long c'était 70 km je suis
tout seul donc voilà ils m'ont soulagé
de 500 m c'est
cool con pas
ouais j'ai pris vraiment mon pied j'ai
pris beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup plus
que d'habitude le fait d'être seul le
fait de gérer ma vitesse et le fait de
toujours avoir de l'accueil des gens pas
avoir de filtre en fait parce que avoir
un guide c'est avoir un filtre j'ai pas
eu ça depuis le début et fait c'est ça
que j'attendais de ce voyage et du coup
genre de journée que je veux vivre
régulièrement qui t qui m'enlevé des
coles extrêmement difficiles réputé et
cetera rigur je m'en fous quoi je
préfère rencontrer des gens et partager
des choses et vivre des
émotions
gilet il va bien avec mon
vélo tous les matins j'entretiens mon
vélo pour que les rouages soient bien
réglés
je brosse la chaîne avant de lubrifier
la transmission et c'est parti pour une
folle
journée est de retour espérant que son
vélo va tenir le coup jusqu'au bout de
[Musique]
l'aventure 20 jours déjà que nous cpon
sur des chemins escarpés au bord du
[Musique]
vide
les routes sont un peu plus praticables
à présent et nous prenons du plaisir à
engranger les kilomètres même si les
versants restent abrupte et
dangereux pour ceux qui a des distances
journalières en vélo c'est du simple
[Musique]
trib
dans les vallées nous profitons de
quelques échops installés au bord de la
route
[Musique]
banglad
et
[Musique]
voilà l'étape du jour est presque plate
100 km à
parcourir c'est la course mais qu'est-ce
que ça fait du
[Musique]
bien
et à chaque fois que je lui passe devant
engang se fait un plaisir de me
[Musique]
rattraper nous mangeons la
poussière c'est assez intéressant pour
une étape plate je pensais que serait
plus plus plus chiant et en fait la fin
c'était assez varié et tout surtout il
faisait la course enfin il il
m'attendait au au kilomè 0 là il me dit
ouais ouais ça fait 11 minutes que je
suis là j'avais dit que j'arri à 11h
jeis arrivve à 11h1 il est vraiment dans
une course quotidienne et en fait je me
rendcte jour après jour du coup je suis
resté à 90 % avec lui et puis après je
le laiss faire ces trucs parce que c'est
de l'énergie pour rien mais c'est dur là
il fait je sais pas il faire un peu plus
de 25 peut-être 30° c'est une route de
travaux en fait en travaux là du coup on
prit beaucoup poussière c'est drôle mais
ça m'a bien plu ça fait du
bien je suis fatigué mais je vais me
remettre
rapidement il
faut
[Applaudissements]
nous avons passé la semaine la plus
intense depuis le départ nous avons fait
plus de 300 km et 20000 m de dénivelés
positifs nous entrons dans le parc
national du
ouvert en
1976 ce fut la première zone protégée de
l'Himalaya on y trouve le très rare
pandarou et son invisible prédateur le
léopard des neiges qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas
croiser ici la majorité de la population
est
amang il vivent essentiellement du bois
qu'ils peuvent récolter dans les
[Musique]
forêts
il a pas beaucoup d'occidentaux qui sont
venus ici avec un vélo c'est hyper
difficile de faire du vélo ici c'est
hyper difficile d'en amener un déjà là
on va vers
manaselou manaselou 8e sommet du monde
donc on va retourner un peu plus dans la
neige un peu plus sur des terrains très
escarpés avec beaucoup de portages donc
un peu moins mon terrain mais je vais
prendre beaucoup de plaisir je
[Applaudissements]
pense
[Musique]
certaines journées sont de véritable
cécure je dois porter mon vélo 10h
[Musique]
durant dans l'effort je cherche à
m'oublier cette aventure c'est aussi une
quête personnelle plus spirituelle
ce sont des heures de méditation et j'en
apprends beaucoup sur
moi-même mais à l'arrivée au sommet d'un
col c'est un sentiment incroyable de
liberté de fierté découvrant une
nouvelle perspective un nouveau but à
atteindre c'est la délivrance enfin
presque parce que rouler sur la neige ce
n'est pas facile non plus
[Musique]
super
chute on va la refaire quand
[Musique]
même à 4380 m d'altitude le lac de Gosa
Kunda apparaît devant nous
[Musique]
majestueux c'est un lie célèbre surtout
pour les pèlerins hindou et
bouddhistes selon la légende c'est le
die Shiva assoifffé qui a créer le lac
en perçant un glacier avec son trident
pour obtenir de
[Musique]
l'eau
petite pause bien
[Musique]
méritée
nous poursuivons sur des chemins plus
que dangereux je n'ai droit ni à la
maladresse ni à l'erreur de freinage pas
même un petit malaise sans quoi la chute
me serait certainement
[Musique]
fatale
la fin de la journée nous offre
finalement une petite heure de
[Musique]
vélo mais cette heure est d'une ivresse
invraisemblable
[Musique]
indescriptible
petite surprise pour mon
anniversaire fter ces 33 ans dans
l'Himalaya ce n'est pas donné à tout le
monde c'est une belle
[Musique]
émotion
ouais la cuisine n'est pasaise est
variée
smise aux influences de l'Inde et de la
Chine mais tous les jours depuis le
départ nous mangeons un dalbat lentill
riz et cuure de légumes j'avoue le
dalbat j'en ai plus que
marre
K
je n'ai rien dans
les nous poursuivons à travers une forêt
qui a brûlé il n'y a pas si
longtemps ces derniers jours de nombreux
feux se sont déclarés d Sant plusieurs
centaines
[Musique]
d'hectares
j'ai toujours adoré le feu il y a
quelque chose de si pur dans la flamme
de si
fort moi aussi je sens mon corps qui
brûle j'ai de la fièvre
ouis je suis je suis
fatigué très fatigué hier j'ai passé une
journée un peu en enfer j'ai
passé 6h 6h difficiles après jour de
repos je savais que ça allait être dur
mais
pas pas à ce point là quoi je dois avoir
un petit virus ou un
petit un petit truc qui me travaille je
suis je suis un peu
fatigué du coup j'ai dormi de 17h à 6h
ce
matin ce qui m'est jamais arrivé dans ma
vie mais mon corps il a peut-être besoin
de de de s'arrêter là mais ça va pas
être demain la veille donc je essayer de
m'accrocher je pense que dans 3 4 jours
ça va aller mieux quoi mais c'est la
deuxième fois depuis le début que j'ai
des petits
passages un peu en enfer là il y a de
jours dur mais pas non plus cauchemard
d'esque
donc donc que je suis confiant sur ma
capacité à les faire après dans quel
étage je vais les faire je sais pas mais
ouais une aventure comme ça il y a des
hauts et des bas il y a beaucoup de a
beaucoup de bas j'ai je suis dans un bas
là c'est un peu violent
ouais ça ira mieux ça ira mieux dans
dans 34 jours
pr pour tenir toute la journée surtout
le matin il ne faut pas partir trop
[Musique]
vite
les Ners sont
àf avec la maladie mon corps est à rue
d'épreuv je dois gérer mon effort de
longues heures
durant
[Musique]
à part quelques larmes je ne lâche rien
je suis venu pour ça me dépasser
physiquement et tenir le coup
[Musique]
mentalement c'est une lutte quotidienne
une concentration de Ch instant mais la
scinene fatigue du corps après une
journée de lente progression m'apporte
la paix
[Musique]
intérieure
heureusement les villageois sont
magnifique sourire aux lèvres j'en
oublie la
douleur ils sont tous que je suis venu
chercher ici des moments unique et de
partage même si on ne se comprend pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toujours j'ai passé l'enfer ce matin
j'ai rarement été aussi mal
psychologiquement surtout mais on a une
lumière de fou là c'est un joli c'est un
joli village et les gens sont hyper
hyper accueillant mais ais c'était on
croyait que c'était une journée cool il
y a jamais de journée cool en fait je
pense qu'il faut se mettre dans la
tê ne restez pas
là laissez-les poussez-vous à qui est ce
petit c'est mon petit
fils les millions de népalis R une
centaine de cast et de groupes ethniqu
et l' ne compte pas les langues et les
dialectes c'est difficile de
communiquer par contre ils ont tous un
remarquable sens de l'hospitalité même
dans les villages les plus
[Musique]
reculés
là c'est donc qui les an
transporteurs ils sont à vide en fait
ils vont jusquen haut et ils reviennent
ils reviennent avec le le
chef ils ont tous entre entre 25 et 30
kg de chaque côté donc 50 60 des fois
plus par selon l'âge et la fatigue mais
ils sont en très mauvais état il sont
pas du tout considér coû Mo cherun
humain en transport donc il s'en fout il
les util et pu les j comme beaucoup de
choses ici pas à la poubelle mais il
j pas M pas voil triste
trte
Dony
ça fait 2 jours qu'on longe la rivière
en fait le treking du de manaselou c'est
longer la rivière et monter petit à
petit c'est souvent ça mais
là c'est il fait chaud il fait je pense
qu'il fait plus de 25 deg etang à peu
près un problème toutes les heures avec
son vélo donc je crains le la défection
mécanique dans la dans la journée je
pense soit une soit
une
r un
souci un vélo chinois il est be mais
c'est fabriqué en
Chine est
bien pas
sintérieur
aventure
on est mal placé la bord du dernier col
5 km avant
l'arrivée on est un queue de
peloton on va avoir du mal à doubler ses
anes là avant le le checkpoint du
repas ils sont pas maigres mais ils sont
pas gros non plus
non c'est dangereux parce que sil nous
mettent un petit coup de sac de riz là
je pense qu'on va directement dans
l'eau et normalement c'est pas plus de
100 kg le
pont nous poursuivons toujours vers
l'ouest pour la plupart des touristes
découvrir l'vresse le plus haut sommet
du monde surpasse l'atrait des coles les
plus élevé moi je v montrer l'inconnu je
veux voir d'autres montagnes tout aussi
[Applaudissements]
fascinantes en fait quand je leur dis
non c'est c'est que c'est que je sens
que ils sont pas en capacité de jouer
avec mon vélo
[Musique]
et
non
j'essaie de jouer les méchants mais
finalement je les laisse tester mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vélo nous entrons dans le district de
Gorka une région importante pour
l'histoire du pays car c'est le roi du
Gorka qui est au 18e siècle réussi à
unifier certains États indépendants des
cont trop fort de l'Himalaya pour fonder
le Népal
moderne les gorkas sont réputés pour
leur simplicité et leur
honnêeté ah il m'a pété dessus ah
ah ah il m'a pété dessus ah il est
[Musique]
dé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la végétation pourrait faire penser
qu'on
est on est en France mais mais non on
est on est bien dans
l'Himalaya dans la région de manaselou
là et la végétation est est flamboyante
c'est hallucinant parce qu'on est on est
à plus de 2000 m et
surtout la la pureté quoi c'est c'est
hyper propre c'est hyper on sent que
c'est naturel même si ce chemin on voit
aussi qu'il a été bien travaillé pour
les touristes et bien élargi
même tu es plus habile que
moi va doucement quand même
sur la route des manies des Pierr gravé
de formule bouddhiste sacré au Pays des
Neiges tous ces symboles sont
omniprésents dans la vie
quotidienne
i
[Musique]
po m
pieds du de fois par
jour
le
ça c'est ça représente une entrée de
village en fait tous les villages ont un
drapeau toutes les régions on un drapeau
et et ça c'est comme nous n point carte
blanche et rouge avec marqué les noms de
ville en gros bah ça c'est la même chose
ici avec un drapeau de drapeau de prière
pour accueillir les gens qui arrivent et
le z la
[Musique]
bienvenue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a un grand privilège aujourd'hui on a
on a rencontré trois trois monqu là on
est dans le on est dans le monastère un
très très beau monastère il y a certains
mon qui viennent d'ailleurs du du Boutan
donc le pays le plus plus heureux du
monde ils ont commencé à 5h et ils
finissent à 21h30 le soir et là on a
visité l'intérieur l'intérieur du
monastère c'est très très beau et on a
eu beaucoup de
chance longtemps que vous êtes au
monastère combien de temps 6 ans 6 ans
et toi
11 ans c'est long tu as un moine
maintenant un grand
moine quel
âge-tu 20 ans 23 23
ans et toi 17
[Musique]
ans
il est 4h du matin on est Samo en
direction de l'arc et pass il fait zéro
ou moins de zéro là je suis
congelé on est parti pour une journée de
de 8 10h
donc j'ai perdu mes gants hier ça
çaon bien il fait très froid on a pas
beaucoup mangé on a pas trop de bouffe
tout va bien j'espère que ça va aller
pour tout le
monde
nous grimpons à la lampe frontale dans
la fraîcheur de la nuit mais les
premières lueurs du jour ne se font pas
attendre nous respirons
difficilement ça c'est manaselou
8e sommet du monde pour moi c'est le
plus beau sommet que j'ai j'ai vu
jusqu'à maintenant c'est assez
impressionnant de de pureté la neige il
doit y avoir un bon M50 làhaut là donc
ouais c'est à mon avis c'est un sommet
très très compliqué à gravir en cette
période l'Himalaya est une demeure
hostile où l'homme doit parfois se
résigner à chaque pas je dois redoubler
d'attention malgré la fatigue et le
manque
d'oxygène mal des Mones
reste un qui 1h non 40 minutes je
pense ça va être très long il moment
qu'on bascule et que je mange je suis en
hipo depuis qu'on est
parti on mange pas assez c'est c'est
dangereux pour moi c'est
dangereux le manque d'énergie et la
fatigue qui s'accumule depuis 36 jours
deviennent mon quotidien
c'est dur mais cette aventure c'est allé
au bout de moi-même pour réaliser mon
rêve pour cela je dois me
[Musique]
surpasser
on vient d'assister à une à une belle
avalanche qui est descendu presque
jusqu'à nous c'était assz impressionnant
on a eu la chance de pas de pas être en
dessous parce que
là que le
souffle très très impressionnant et le
bruit
ouais on sent que c'est puissant quoi je
pense qu'on va pas traîner ici très
[Musique]
longtemps là on est on est à plus de
5000 m ça fait une adaptation
cardioespiratoire et
cardiovasculaire assez
importante en gros on enchie c'est c'est
dur mais mais après voilà c'est c'est un
col on bascule et derrière derrière ça
va mieux quoi donc on récupère 13 km en
5 6 he d'effort voilà vous pouvez
mesurer la difficulté de l'effort parce
qu'on n pas on est des sportifs quand
même accomplis et du coup
ouais c'est c'est dur c'est un bel
effort je suis sur le toit
et je suis heureux
enfin rapidement nous redescendons au
milieu des lauriers et des mythiques
rodau
d'indrons nous sommes à 15 jours de
l'arrivée nous voici à présent dans les
Anapurna c'est la région la plus visitée
du Népal elle délivre plus de permis que
[Musique]
l'Everest sur le chemin des moulins à
prièr sont disséminé un peu partout
d'après les croyances populaires la
rotation du moulin éloig les mauvais
esprits les maladies et la
[Musique]
malchance aujourd'hui ça va être
beaucoup plus simple que les autres
jours parce qu'on va pouvoir rouler
[Musique]
longtemps dit qu'on roulait
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
journé les gens me demandent souvent
qu'est-ce qui te pousse à faire ça
qu'est-ce qui
pourquoi ces projets pourquoi
ces ces excès
c'est en fait c'est ma maison ici il y a
que là que je me sens vraiment vraiment
bien et vraiment moi donc ça aucun
intérêt de monter un sommet comme ça
mais mais là on va vivre un truc de fou
parce que là on en a pour 2 heures de
descente et et on a réussi quoi on a
réussi quelque chose et on a réussi
grâce à nous quoi
c'est personne nous l'a donné on est
dans des sociétés de commun
de réseau là le réseau réseau il existe
plus là on est on est chacun face à
nousmême mais en même temps on est
solidaire on est et c'est ça le plus
beau parce que là on est dans un paysage
extraordinaire c'est c'est presque
lunaire moi je me sens jamais aussi bien
que lorsque je suis au sommet d'une
montagne donc
ouais dépassez-vous dépassez-vous et
n'oubliez jamais n'oubliez jamais vos
rve bonheur il est pas dans
l'enfermement dans l'ostracisme et
compagnie il est dans la dans le partage
dans dans le dépassement quel qu'il soit
mais là là je suis
[Musique]
heureux
moi je sais pas ce qui est vraiment
l'ordinaire en tous les cas j'essaie
d'aller toujours plus loin dans la
recherche de moi-même dans la recherche
de l'autre aussi parce que là on a
évidemment rencontré beaucoup de gens
sur notre passage je connaissais une
partie infime du Népal j'en connais
beaucoup plus et à chaque fois que je
visite un pays c'est ce que j'essaie de
faire même si c'est parfois succin c'est
parfois parfois qu'un regard ou qu'un
sourire ou qu'un amasté mais ce genre
d'aventure c'est pas qu'une aventure
individuelle c'est pas que projet de de
dépassement de soi c'est c'est du vrai
la vraie
découverte profonde de soi et des autres
donc ouais c'est ça rêve d'Himalaya mais
il y aura d'autres rêves
ailleurs il y en aura d'autres ici j'en
suis sûr parce que je suis je suis
amoureux de ce pays je suis amoureux de
ces
gens
à 10 jours de la fin les choses
s'accélèrent nous portons de moins en
moins nos
vélos nous traversons des paysages
déchirés déchiquetés par l'érosion ils
sont asséchés par les
vents blanchis par la neige mais ils
sont d'une telle beauté ici je
m'abandonne
[Musique]
complètement
ah le
[Musique]
bonheur presce que j'en ai
chié c'est l'un des derniers territoires
encore véritablement sauvages sur la
planète un lieu sacré où l'homme n'a que
très peu sa
place d'ailleurs le peuple népalais a
bien compris que face à la nature il
valait mieux faire profil
[Musique]
bas les tremblements de terre sont
fréquents et meurtriers
les moussons emportent les routes les
épidémies ravagent les
[Musique]
villages
waouh
TR face à nous les montagnes de la
démesure authentique
[Musique]
nature
l' 5000 de là le vélo que j'aime c'est
d'arriver comme ici dans des endroits
incroyables je suis devenu cycliste pour
ça pour l'aventure et la
découverte de l'aube au crépuscule et
parfois dans la nuit nous avançons dans
la solitude et l'asphexie de
l'altitude je suis sur le chemin de mon
âme une méditation
extrême
[Musique]
voà je dirais que là ça passe enne de
l'eau hein on va le savoir tout de suite
c'est soit oui soit c'est l'hôpital ah
ouais ah ouais bien joué
ou là
là va se prendre pour un npalais comme
[Musique]
ça
yeah
bienvenue à toi aussi
bienvenue venez on fait une
[Musique]
[Rires]
photo
[Musique]
ક
ce qu'on appelle un jour
100 ça faisait 15 jours que ça
m'était pas arrivé
ah
c'est c'est long c'est long c'est long
j'ai pas de force il fait chaud très
humide
je suis hyper
faible c'est
horrible les derniers jours sont les
plus
difficiles j'ai de nouveau un virus qui
m'affaiblit je suis à
bout je puise le peu d'énergie qu'il me
reste pour boucler l'aventure dans la
neige et le
froid nous sommes à 200 km du
but mon vélo je voudrais le jeter
l'écraser c'est bien la première
[Applaudissements]
fois mais nous sommes au Népal
le pays qui a vu naître le Boudha un
endroit béni des dieux alors je cherche
au plus profond de moi les capacités de
continuer
jeain je vis en
enfer
je
[Musique]
comment allez-vous
bien monsieur le professeur il parle pas
bien
anglais c'est quoi ton nom
[Musique]
non pardonne-moi comment tu
t'appelles à 100 km de l'arrivée je me
retrouve seul sur la
route ce matin pli de douleur n'a pas pu
se lever sans doute le dalb de la veille
moi si près du but je continue jusqu'au
bout la tête dans les nuages je termine
donc seul mon rêve
d'Himalaya
[Musique]
dernière fois que je porte mon
vélo dernière
ascension va le faire pres que 60 B
si vous voyez une route qui serpente
dites-vous que c'est là que je veux être
tous les jours je veux être libre sur
mon
vélo découvrir à chaque virage un
nouveau paysage un nouvel objectif à
[Musique]
atteindre
derrière ces montagnes c'est la Chine le
Tibet enfin après 51 jours d'aventure
2000 km parcourus et 90000 m de dénivelé
positif j'arrive à Ilsa au milieu de
nulle part sur les
[Musique]
genoux je suis hyper ému d'être
là je vais pas craquer là mais c'est
beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotions
[Musique]
euh je suis un
peu je suis un peu
bouleversé
allez enfin bref je suis je suis fier je
suis fier de
moi ça sent le
craquage le craquage total de nerf mais
voilà difficile de ne pas
craquer comment vivre normalement après
ça je regrette que hang ne soit pas là
pour partager cette émotion mais je suis
heureux fatigué mais
heureux le Népal pour moi c'est une
évidence je reviendrai c'est certain
avec mon vélo jouet les acrobates sur le
toit du
monde aujourd'hui je suis fier et quand
je ferme les yeux je rêve de ma
prochaine
[Musique]
aventure